the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
yeah greg was not here yesterday he was
away and so this is work he's largely
done on his own again he's done in
molecular dynamics simulator so he's
gonna tell us a little bit about that
and then after that we'll do course
evaluations hand out some awards have
some cake and then after that some pizza
and then play some PlayStation 3 ok so
I'll talk about the general molecular
dynamics algorithm and then
parallelization approaches ok so
molecular dynamics is based on a
potential energy function which includes
two terms bonded terms and non bonded
terms and bonded terms are split up into
three sub terms and the the bond so
don't confuse bond that with actually
don't don't think that these are non
bonded these are actually all sort of
group that is bond that I know it's a
little bit confusing but right now I'm
dealing just with the sort of bonded
terms and what that means is that it
deals with atoms that are connected
together covalently so for example the
bonds term reflects some energy due to a
displacement of between two atoms which
are a certain distance apart there is an
equilibrium distance that they like to
stay with at and if they vary from that
distance the potential the potential
increases as a squared of that
separation distance the angles term
represents basically the deviation from
an equilibrium angle between three atoms
so if you imagine these three nodes as
three atoms if this angle varies away
from a certain equilibrium theta or
angle then the potential energy is also
quadratic term
which tends to bring the the three atoms
to have a certain equilibrium angle and
then finally the dihedral and improper
term it's probably one of the more
complicated ones the improper term
basically deals with four atoms so if
you imagine this is one two three and
four these three atoms if you put two
planes through them the angle that those
two planes make to each other is given a
certain equilibrium angle again and this
is also this is this should also be a
quadratic term but the energy also
varies quadratically as that angle is
deviated from and an actual dihedral is
the rotation along a bond between the
two central atoms and this this energy
term has actually a cosine form so so as
you rotate along this bond say for
example the energy will vary
sinusoidally and there'll be a restoring
potential that will tend to make it you
know either a line or sometimes it will
make the atom stagger so these are all
very all of these parameters are very
sort of molecule and atom dependent and
all of these parameters are available or
have been built over many years by
different methods like ivanishin
calculations or experimental
calculations but basically if you plug
those parameters in for example here k
represents the the the spring constant
right cuz you're basically just like
spring constraints more or less or in
this case it will tell you how far up
the potential like what this value will
be at the maximum and and we'll for
example in this case we'll specify how
many of these how many fluctuations you
have in the energy function and the
other parameters are usually the theta
the equilibrium theta or the equilibrium
or the equilibrium bond length or so
this is kind of what you can expect for
it to look like as as molecules will
tend to
move okay the non-bonded terms include
vander waals terms and electrostatic
terms so Van der Waals forces occur
between any two atoms and if they're far
if they're far far enough apart they
will attract they will attract to each
other according to this formula and if
they're too close together so at the
equilibrium distance between them the
energy is a minimum but as they get any
closer there will be a very strong
repulsive force which is the arts of the
twelfth term and as they get further
apart
there's a an attraction force which
varies as R to the sixth and then the
electrostatic force is just a just a
simple Coulomb big form so you basically
take two atoms that are say oppositely
charged will attract each other if
they're positively charged they will
repel each other and it's just a matter
of multiplying the charges and then
dividing by R to get the energy okay so
to do molecular dynamics basically you
have to take derivatives of all those
formulas I just showed you and I didn't
do that all myself who is pretty hard I
just got some code from some current
existing molecular dynamics simulators
but basically take the derivative and
that basically equates to the force
write the typical Newtonian model and
that gives you the force on every atom
and then using that force an integration
scheme this is the vert of the leapfrog
valet integration scheme just gives you
the velocity at the next night wall at
the next half time step and then using
that velocity at the half time step the
positions are of the of each atom is
updated based on the positions at the
previous time step and then some and
then some value so I will show you a
little bit of what it looks like on a
simple molecule first so here's a sort
of simple molecule and it has just an
initial configuration that is this sort
of random
and so if I just take the four so one
technique that is done is first the
geometry is minimized which means that
you just take small steps in the
direction of the gradient until he
reached the energy minimum and if I do
that I sort of reach the sort of the
minimum configuration that this molecule
likes to be in and then if I had some
thermal noise which means that I just
set the initial velocities of the atoms
to some random temperate random value
based on the temperature then the
molecule starts to ridiculous aggression
scheme is that it's actually just right
like the energy is conserved in the
system although fluctuates a little bit
so a lot of integration schemes the
energy tends to either decrease or
increase so the system explodes but this
integration scheme is very stable one
thing that you saw there is okay so I
just talked about briefly about kinetic
energy this is kind of how the initial
velocities are set based on the
Boltzmann constant and the temperature
and the other thing that molecular
dynamics usually do is called Langevin
dynamics and in this case some random
velocity vector is added to the normal
velocity which just makes sort of
simulates collisions with other
molecules in the environment so this
makes the simulation look a bit more
realistic so instead of the molecule
just sitting there in space this random
sort of factor adds some movement and
there's also some damping constant which
sort of opposes the velocity by some
constant so if so if if you didn't add
any more sort of randomness into the
system the system would just eventually
go to to be completely still so so there
would be no more movement because this
is kind of like a damping sort of factor
and there are some properties of the of
this random vector that sort of makes
some physical sense for example it's
independent of previously picked random
vectors and it also depends on the
temperature so that if you keep adding
this random factor to the simulation the
temperature will always stay constant
another thing to consider is that these
molecules if you try to think of them as
inner as they are in a sort of typical
biological system is that they'll be
solvated in water so in that case the
that the columbic term is not actually
that simple you have to include some
sort of dielectric constant so for
example one that is typically used and
it's pretty simple is that the the
constant is just the distance so that
makes the electrostatic energy dependent
on one over R squared rather than one
over R so that means that the
electrostatic forces drop off much a lot
faster as you go as the atoms get
further and further apart so for example
if so two molecules that are oppositely
charged if they're if you just put them
in vacuum they will eventually come
close together but if if you add this
term the the electrostatic attraction
will be much weaker so it will simulate
it than being soul mated in water and
they will get they will come together
eventually but probably a lot slower
another thing that is typically so so
I'll talk a little bit about the
non-bonded forces right now which are
again the electrostatic forces and van
der Waals forces so generally what has
to be done is if you consider any single
atom like say this one over here well
okay so first of all the bonded forces
are basically include just the atoms
that are connected to it
and that's it so it's pretty it's
usually the fastest step in the
computation but for non-bonded forces
you have to consider basically every
other atom in the system so done and I
didn't include all the atoms here but
basically just to give an idea they
could be atoms that are really far apart
so generally what's done is there is
some cut off radius outside of which
those forces aren't considered and
because the forces drop off really fast
sometimes that's considered to be good
enough for a lot of simulations so
that's a consideration to take into
account when doing these simulations
okay so here's the basic molecular
dynamics algorithm so first so you
specify how many steps you want to run
it to and I didn't say the times the
time step each time step is one
femtosecond
so very small so four so usually what
happens is you can find the atom pairs
so that means all the non-bonded
interactions you have to make a list
basically an N squared list if you have
n atoms you can expect to have about n
squared atom pairs but if you consider a
cut-off then what's usually done is only
atom only atom pairs with that cutoff
within that cutoff are considered and
included into that list and and that
computation is pretty expensive so it's
sometimes only done only a certain every
say every ten steps and atoms don't
really move that much so it's usually a
pretty accurate and if anything is a
cut-off of say 15 angstroms and then all
the forces are dropped to almost zero by
12 banks terms then that's pretty
accurate so this is usually an
optimization it optimizes the simulation
a little bit the next step is to compute
the bonded forces so that includes the
bonds angles like he'd rose and improper
angles and then the NAM and then compute
the non-bonded forces so that iterates
over all the atom pairs and then the
integration is done to obtain the new
item positions so here's a running on
the PlayStation this is kind of roughly
how like the this is just running on the
PPU alone so finding the atom pairs if I
don't use a card off I can just compute
the atom pairs list once and I never do
it again so that's why I put here zero
but otherwise generally takes a lot of
time to compute the atom pairs because
it involves getting the distances
between every every two atoms and for
this is a system with this is a pretty
big system maybe about a thousand atoms
so that's why so this is these times are
not really representative of smaller
systems but bf is so that's done using
the brute force approach so that means
that he check every every two atoms and
this is the key this is using a KD tree
so that breaks space up and then you get
a so then the checking the neighboring
atoms is n log N or it's actually a
constant factor
you built the tree building the trees
and login so using that kind of an
algorithm you get much better improved
much better improvement so this this is
a scaling of increasing the system size
by two and the number of atoms so say
going from a thousand to two thousand
atoms the time to we using the brute
force a brute force approach increases
exponentially whereas using a KD tree it
actually just about doubles so that kind
of you know shows that using a better
algorithm sometimes for these things is
probably much better than trying to
paralyze it doing the bonded forces say
about 50 milliseconds and with cutoff
it's the same time because it doesn't
really affect the step but then the
non-competing the non born non-bonded
forces is actually the biggest chunk of
time so that takes about 1.4 seconds for
this system and then this is considering
a million pairs with a cut-off there is
less pairs to consider but the time is
still the dominant time basically so so
generally for molecular dynamic
simulations this is the dominant time
factor and that's what people really
focus on trying to speed things up and
then the integration is really fast
because it just loops over the atoms
once so there is basically three
different paralyzation approaches that
I've come across in the literature and
one of them is you can is refer to as
force decomposition so if you think of
the force force operation being say a
non bonded force operation where you
consider two atoms and you compute the
force you know due to Vander Waals and
electrostatic forces one easy way to
split this up amongst say six processors
is to just give each processor say and
divided by six of these force operations
the first operation includes so you have
to send each processor both the atom
position both atom positions and then
some other properties of the atoms like
such as the mass and action at the mass
but the charges and the minimum radius
and basically once that computation is
done the processor just has to either
store or return the
worse on both Adam and it has to come
back to sort of like the main processor
where all the forces are added up and
then the integration is done so what I
just described this sort of the approach
I took and it's sort of an easy approach
to sort of think of if you only had if
he couldn't store say every item on
every processor because you just have to
send each processor a certain number of
these force computation units and the
processor does them and then we turns
the forces and then you can just add up
all the forces on every atom and do that
so basically here is the algorithm how
it works roughly and I'll just so
basically first set up the SPU's send
the control box with say the addresses
where all these force operations will be
stored the the bond the forces are
computed on the PPU just for simplicity
for now and and then the computation for
the non Bourne the force is basically
all all the non-bonded forces operations
remaining are considered and then
they're split up into blocks so each SPU
sent a block would say a number of force
operations and in this case it was 200
so the control block is sent to the SPU
the SPU is told to start processing and
then the PPU waits for each SPU to
finish and then once that once the SP is
finished the forces are added to the two
atoms that are involved in that first
computation and then and then this loop
is done once all the SPU's are finished
and then it goes in this repeats until
there is non bonded operations remaining
so for example here just to illustrate
this let's say these are all the non
bonded operations I have to do and I'm
gonna use two SPU's and each SPU can
only store say 3 force operations so
each block so each SPU is sent by a
block I mean that say these three
operations are sent to each SPU the SPU
does them the next block is sent to the
next SPU at the same time and then that
SP also does it and this is iteration
zero for example and this is done until
all of the force computations are done
so here is a time
so you might imagine that as I said
there's a lot of there's a lot of
communication overhead over here so it's
actually so here's how this performs so
on the under ppyou the whole AMD
simulation for per time step runs in
three hundred and ten milliseconds
unless a one on one SPU the time goes up
to 630 milliseconds so there's a lot of
communication already air on to SPU's it
goes back down to 390 and as the number
of SPS is increased it gets lower and
lower but it doesn't get it's not that
much better than really running it
sequentially and the reason is that the
way I implemented it it's kind of it's
pretty rough one of the limitations is
that I mean one at one very obvious
optimization that should be done is that
the SPU basically waits for this whole
block to arrive and then starts
computation but really what what I
should have done is to what once once
one force computation arrives you can
already do that computation and then
instead of waiting for all of them to
get to be transferred and then starting
to do the operation so that I think that
could have been a lot better no no so
right so this is this is sort of the
simplest approach I mean that was sort
of a simple approach to implement on
this architecture and a sort of scales
world as the system grows so if you
can't store every atom for example in
every SPU this doesn't it doesn't this
doesn't really care you can really the
system can grow as large as you want
there's some other approaches that are
done sort of in the literature I didn't
implement these but another one is
called atomic decomposition so here if
you obviously a number of atoms you send
each one of these atoms to one SPU and
then that SPU is solely responsible for
completing the forces on it and and also
integrating to get the new positions and
then all you have to communicate is the
atomic positions but this is a little
bit more complicated
because then you also have to have yeah
every SPU has to know about all of the
force computations that you want to do
so for example in this case is just an
unbonded but all the other force yes the
ESPE also has to know about yeah it
would be the only problem yeah the only
problem with that approach is that if
the system was much larger than the SP
you could store then you couldn't store
every single atom on the SPU then an
operation might refer to atoms that are
not there so so so yeah it would be
similar to that but it would get more
complicated in this case as the system
grew because you'd have to keep track of
where each atom is and then implement
communication if you don't have a
certain atom to get that out in position
and use it in the force computation so
yeah this this approach okay I'll talk a
little bit more about this this is uh
that's true yeah so you only sort of
give a certain number of atoms to every
SPU and then yeah that's true and then
you would have to sort of store every
single force that that atom is his wrist
is included in on the SPU yeah yeah you
know like the prot one this will become
a problem as they say the system was
much larger than he had then yeah local
store then say you had like a tenth of
the system on SPU's and then 9/10 of the
system on the PPU
there wouldn't be yeah it would be hard
to sort of think of as scaling properly
on but um so a special case of this
atomic decomposition is actually spatial
decomposition okay I'm also so a special
case of spatial decomposition where what
makes so what makes this approach sort
of not good and it sort of involves a
lot of communication is just this fact
that you some of these force
computations or force operations that
you have could include atoms on
different units so if you don't split up
these atoms sort of smartly then you
could end up with a lot of having to
communicate a lot while computing these
forces
so especially composition tries to
address this and basically you store
atoms that are close to each other so
say I had the system and I wanted to
split this up into on six SPU's then
right I would give each SPU say a
certain area of space but you could see
right away what the problem with this is
is that it's not load balance so some
SPD's could be not could not have too
much work to do and you know and there's
still some communication because you
have to communicate between neighboring
SPU say in some certain cases but the
communication is still probably a lot
better than then in the previous case
just for Tommy decomposition so here's
the state of the art on this on
paralyzation MD and it's it's
implemented in this program called NAMD
and it's which stands for not or not of
not another that molecular dynamic
simulator so this this this initially
named 1.0 used the space they used
solely a spatial decomposition and they
try to address this load-balancing by
actually creating many more patches and
you have processors and and then you
just sort of split these patches up
load-balanced them amongst the different
processors that didn't really work so
now i'm one then paralyzed very well so
what they added later was they added
this idea of patch objects and also
compute objects so basically a patch
object looks puts one of these puts a
number of patches on a processor but
then you can also create compute patches
which which include all of these force
operations and these force operation
should also equally distributed amongst
processors and then there's a lot of
communication between these two and it
started off with sort of a message
orient write message oriented
communication then it moved to a
dependency Orient's communication so so
that each compute object would sort of
signal which atoms and needs and it also
sort of optimized things by by doing a
communication and force computation at
the same time so did that really well
and actually it has really good parallel
performance so here on this graph it
shows the the number of processors times
the time per time
step and as the number of processors is
increased yep I mean optimal parallel
performance would be a straight
horizontal line which is pretty close to
what they achieve and they also did it
on many thousands of processors either
on blue jean but as you might expect the
more processors you add the step time
actually still sort of levels off at a
certain time so I guess I'll skip the
line the sort of live them I was gonna
do but I'll just show one more thing so
here is sort of the the kind of systems
that I was looking at this is actually
simulation that was done on one of the
PP use and then recorded in a positions
file and there is five different
molecules here I'll just make them so
you're generally what happens is first
they're just placed randomly then there
an overlap just very coarsely to make
sure that they don't you know huge
forces aren't added into the system and
I'll just color each one differently so
here's what happens during the
simulation and here in this simulation
actually every the positions were
recorded every 20 time steps so that's
why it sort of seems to go a lot faster
if I did it on a single molecule and I
should've done that first so here's what
a single molecule of this looks like and
this is a protein with eight residues
which is pretty big and this is running
in real time on my computer right now so
a small protein like on a small system
like this it runs reasonably fast but as
you add more and more of these things
the computations do get pretty expensive
so parallelization really helps
well not and then what I implemented but
generally generally as you saw nam can
do a pretty good job at doing it okay I
didn't minimize the system well enough
but yeah that's about it
you managed to get yeah baby yeah
exactly so let's go into the extent that
I when Lester took a long time so